today we're going to be making bacon
wrapped Oreos in the smoker with a touch
of sea salt
before you pass judgment on these just
try them
start with a package of Oreos and bacon
take a single strip of bacon and wrap
that around an Oreo to see how much
excess is left over and then you can cut
the rest of that excess off the bacon so
you have perfectly sized strips now just
wrap up the rest of your Oreos you want
to do it fairly Loose as the bacon Cooks
it contracts and you don't want it to
squish your Oreo then top it with your
favorite barbecue rub and then we added
some smoked flaky salt just to contrast
the sweetness now get these on a rack
and preheat your smoker we'll be smoking
these for an hour at 320 Fahrenheit
foreign
[Music]